[Musique]
à 31 ans Samuel a réalisé son rêve
posséder son propre cheptel dans le
hauteur de la chaloupe Saint- leu ce
fils d'agriculteur a repris
l'exploitation de sa mère l'élevage bvin
est en effet une histoire de famille en
2008 j'ai voulu raorter ma ma petite
touche personnelle à à l'exploitation
parce que comme j'ai repris un héritage
familial je voulais aussi mon projet
personnel donc c'est à ce momentl j'ai
voulu rester dans le beauin parce que
bin correspondait bien on avait
l'équipement on avait les foncier on
avait tout ce qu'il fallait pour le
bovin donc j'ai préféré partir sur sur
production de vach en plus il y a un
manque il un manque énorme en lait ici à
la runion et donc c'était un peu une
opportunité donner un nouvel élan à
l'exploitation mais également moderniser
les équipements dont il hérite c'est
comme cela que Samuel entrevoit son
avenir tout naturellement il se fait
aider demande financement pour pouvoir
atteindre ses objectifs le département
sur les a fader donc on a eu 176000 €
donc sur la sur le bâtiment donc qui
correspond à 70 % plafonné on va dire
parce que 70% c'est le maximum et donc
moi j'ai atteint le maximum vu le
montant deinvestissement et donc il m'a
permis de donc d'acquérir donc un outil
de travail on va dire pointilleux et
aussi confortable euh pour permettre
donc euh la production de de de lait
dans dans ce bâtiment le bâtiment a été
inauguré par le commissaire européen
d'assenolos il est venu ici à la Réunion
donc et puis euh voilà on a inauguré le
bâtiment j'étais content de montrer
aussi euh à Bruxelles de quoi on était
capable il ser à rayon sur une petite
île à 12000 km on va dire une salle de
traite dernier cri avec du matériel
innovant mais aussi une nouvelle manière
de travailler dans le respect de
l'animal nous sommes dans une salle de
traite on appelle une 2 x 4 on peut
traire h vaches à la fois donc on a
quatre postes de chaque côté la machine
à traire petite particularité qu'elle a
c'est qu'elle a un décrro automatique
c'estàd que on branche la vache elle
prend le lait dans dans la mamelle de la
vache et ensuite quand quand la mamê n'a
plus de lait elle va se mettre à
décrocher tout seul ça va éviter de
faire des surites si l'animal est dans
le condition automatiquement elle va
elle va produire sans aucune difficulté
moi je suis aujourd'hui à on va dire 25
kg de moyenne par vache et par
an ce qui correspond à peu près à 7500
kg de litre par par vache et par et par
an et en moyenne calé on est à peu près
à moyen d'élevage calé sur l'ensemble
des éleveurs aujourd'hui dans la coper
calé nous sommes à peu près à 6000 kg un
bâtiment flambant neuf et un rendement
parmi les meilleurs de la salé Samuel
Grondin à 31 ans peut-être fier du
parcours accompli il pourrait mécaniser
encore plus son exploitation mais ce
qu'il recherche avant tout c'est le
contact avec l'animal g du temps mais
après quand on quand quand quand on fait
ça on va aussi perdre le côté le côté le
côté animal c'està dire que j'aurai plus
ce contact là avec les animaux
travailler dur ne pas compter ses or et
surtout être patient c'est le prix de la
réussite selon Samuel Grondin une étable
dévage des pâurages et un excellent lait
Samuel conondin a trouvé sa voix il peut
désormais penser à l'avenir qui pour lui
passera par la
[Musique]
diversification